اكتشاف نقوش حجريات تعد اقدم مخططات
هندسيه معروفه حتى الان ويعود تاريخها الى
تسعه الاف عام هذه النقوش تقعها في مساحات
كبيره كانت مخصصه للصيد في مناطق باتت
اليوم مساحات صحراويه في السعوديه وكذلك
في الاردن وكان طيارون في عشرينيات القناه
الماضيه اول مكتشف هذه المصائب واطلقوا
عليها تسميه الطائرات الورقيه الصحراويه
بسبب الشكل الذي تبدو عليه من الجو وفق
الباحثين في جامعه ليون كان هذا المخطط
الهندسي يتيح نقل المعلومات ومشاركتها بين
اشخاص عده بهدف تنظيم عمليات صيد
الحيوانات
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات